this president has radicalized so many
more people than Isis ever did what what
does she have to gain by lying I present
to you exhibit a question of the day I
believe this off right now it's simple
medias blaming Trump for dividing the
country we see this all the time whereas
most conservatives and of course the
president down Trump thinks the media is
largely responsible and entirely
responsible but largely responsible your
thoughts and by the way his political
division necessarily a bad thing
um what's but I'm ok with calling
someone evil if they falsely accuse you
of gang rape let's just write with that
right now we start talking less people
all how can you call your political
opposition evil hold on a second think
about this really quickly before we get
to the clips if someone walks into your
place of work right now and says he's a
gang rapists or she's a gang rapists
with zero evidence and a bunch of other
people with zero evidence actually don't
corroborated you're like a they're gonna
chromic like actually we weren't there
but what would you say would you man
that's an evil thing to do then your
boss says oh listen
they might have been out of line with
the gang rape accusations but evil okay
so let's set this up this is how the
media has been presenting it here we go
this is his rhetoric that has created
this moment in time and to ignore that
is to ignore a huge component of what's
going on here what okay we don't really
just let's go to Trump's response which
I love the media also has a
responsibility to set a civil tone and
to stop the endless hostility and
constant negative and oftentimes false
attacks and stories have to do it goes
off last part and oftentimes false
attacks have to do it you kind of do it
his mind he's like nailed it every time
one of those stories comes with always
this smug elitist like Trump is the
worst person on the planet he obviously
caused all this it's not true Cronk
divided the country on a second black
lives matter Occupy Wall Street both
tomorrow you know this stuff well right
the lowboys Trump is the one who divided
this country initially remember I talked
about we got into so much trouble on
this program because we which the Obama
hope poster and it said [ __ ]
the point that I made was you're going
to see the night you are going to see
almost to the day and certainly election
night where everyone who was racist who
didn't vote for Obama is going to become
a sexist now we're just all the things
and you can tack on transphobes the list
but you're going to say the president
Donald Trump is one who divided the
country hey gang rapists hey you're evil
man can you believe this guy the nerve
what's more divisive smearing someone
and by proxy all of their political ilk
or pointing out the smearing so let's go
to the top five false smears of Trump
just from the last few weeks all right
here's a obviously the latest one that
Trump this is that Trump is to blame for
the synagogue shooting here yo Dave 6:48
of the Trump administration as the
nation has now witnessed in the space of
just days two acts of domestic terrorism
the second vastly darker than the first
the White House is now consumed by its
effort to defend itself from those who
see the link between the president's
words and what we've witnessed yes you
can find his anti-jewish rhetoric right
next to your rocket fire Brian Williams
frickin asymmetrical genetic and by the
way in case you were wondering the guy
you shot in the synagogue thought Donald
Trump was a secret Jew they just say
they say right they say Nazis hated Jews
Nazis social get rid of socialists their
right-wing therefore anyone doesn't like
Jews right-wing Donald Trump responds
get now Donald Trump's been a huge
supporter of Israel which is actually a
huge reason that the left doesn't like
him as well as the very small minority
of vocal racists in this country don't
believe me the Jews have endured
terrible persecution and you know that
we've all read it we've studied it
they've gone through a lot and those
seeking their destruction we will seek
their yeah but he's anti-semitic seeking
that we will seek a right titled your
landed this plane there
fish strap pause for effect in his head
he's going how do you how do you blame
the last thing you can say about Donald
Trump is it he's an anti-semite no of
course you met his son-in-law yes these
are the same people like Donald Trump's
giving too much power to Kushner and
also he hates Jews alright let's move on
to the next myth that comes to us from
MSNBC that he's a terrorist sympathizer
listen all this has always been a
problem with this president
he has always shown a sympathy or a
dismissiveness towards terrorism is he a
terrorist sympathizer let me just say
things I've never heard that good god
Donald Trump likes terrorists Kevin
Spacey likes women oh I know not to
listen to you actually by the way if
we're gonna talk about actual terrorism
Trump is a much better record than Obama
any certainly the rhetoric which people
have talked about the travel ban yeah
they just don't like listen maybe
Muslims are great a barricade loving
Patriots but the terrorists of the woods
I hate oh really now we're just were
anti terrorist brocco Baba traded terror
baseball trading cards terrorists for
traitors oh gosh a notification bell if
you're subscribed it doesn't mean a
whole lot on YouTube and of course trend
Oakland if you wanna watch the daily
show for people who are not already
subscribed to my club you get seven day
free trial that's what allows us to keep
going on with you the free content you
get some of you look at you about to say
they're never oh I was just gonna point
out how great that black man was lit
like maybe see everything wrong he look
great oh he looks there yeah you know
what he didn't look as dramatic as you
you're like that you're like a Sergio
Leone film and and he also didn't dress
in all black maybe yes maybe we maybe we
both have some distances also also maybe
you shouldn't have so much melanin in
your skin let's be honest he was a shade
just a skosh lighter than you I'm not
even gonna feel bad when I rob all of
you who's perpetuating stereotypes now
sir you know this is just a myth never
say he of course you know the recent the
get her done alarm clock bomb in Jeff
roll the clip this is something they're
going to embrace this is a strata
they are going to move forward with even
in the photo SE Cupp literal bombs sent
to the news media and democrats do you
think the naughty librarian looks still
works I'm 55 no not now I'm just saying
you're about to hit that I used to SE
Cupp I used to spend time with her but I
tuned in to CNN it's like hey SE Cupp
you will only be employed here if you do
nothing but bash Trump got it so long as
it check clears don't take out don't
take our word for it
levar burton right you know levar burton
you know he would say take take the word
take the word of a six-year-old kids for
italy i like the book and reading range
why didn't you just articulate this but
don't take our word for it
trump's actual words on the bomber these
terrorizing acts are despicable and have
no place in our country eivin struggle
place sadly artis despair no resource or
expense in finding those responsible and
bringing them to Swift and certain
justice we will prosecute them him
whoever we V to the fullest extent of
the law
it's pretty cut and dry oh we know it's
a we know it's true folks we know it's
true I gotta get back to my speech book
like I'd like Vince Vaughn hey baby over
here right my first talk it'd
wheeler-dealer not exactly but I there's
something refreshing about just his
response here he was like basically that
was a presidential way of saying he's
top smear number two is actually
Congress person on CNN again we're back
back he's the anti symmetry the
synagogue shooting but his son-in-law
may have ordered the murder of
Washington Post Rose how do we print is
it is it costly no we're gonna hear the
next clip the reporting that Jared
Kushner is a weird-lookin may have with
US intelligence delivered a hit list an
enemies list he's up to the Crown Prince
to MBs in Saudi Arabia
and that the prince then may have acted
on that and one of the people that he
took action against as mr. kiss oh gee
oh so close oh gee there's actually no
evidence of the kosher hit list the
conspiracy theory like you was in a
false-flag lead and uh and your thing
after some initial trepidation regarding
the blaming I'm sorry and I talked about
that was not through I'm not a fan of
Saudi Arabia in any capacity all right I
have a problem when you make women just
like ninjas or the other knowledge I
don't know if they're allowed to drive
now I don't know the exact rules it's
changing all the time they're not
yelling they're definitely not allowed
to use a passing lane I know that after
waiting Trump was pretty harsh on the
Saudis here you go it was carried out of
poorly and the cover-up was one of the
worst in the history of cover-ups it's
very simple bad deal I'll just say
terrible cover-up that's it president
Trump adviser he's like got it like just
trust me says that'll be another good
absolutely I will stop bad deal that
deal frankly they would have said this
guy is not gonna make that deal and I
wouldn't all right number one can number
ones guy I don't want seconds number one
smear against President Donald Trump and
this all ties into their side again the
idea that we're divided and people
sometimes act as though us doing it
change my mind or us frankly just
crashing something just crashing a show
just screw it up because people are out
there indoctrinating children dekha so
that's the same as the kind of political
division that's occurring on mainstream
media everything I don't agree with it I
just don't agree with it if you watch
what the CNN panelist has to say number
one this president has radicalized so
many more people than Isis ever did what
was she talking about the get er done
flags and confused it this president has
radicalized more people than Isis Nimr
can you confirm that like how many
people have been like Mogga and
beheadings like I just electric turkey
Carver I just want to make sure
you all know this is to make America
great no evidence of course at all
synagogue shooter hated Trump thought
that he was a secret Jew all right let's
be really clear this because this was
said in context about that she was true
seniors radicalize more people in Isis
no no she obviously has never met Isis
she has never done any research on what
Isis does come on right you can't even
make that claim with a straight face
I'd try to walk it back they gave her a
chance to on the panel a little bit
later on she did a poor job cert at her
point yeah go watch the clip in its
entirety
what's the take the context for
something by the way I buy that logic of
course Bernie Sanders is inciting people
to remember but I think we have the clip
right yeah it Pelosi's response when
people suggested that Bernie Sanders
radicalized by the way I want to make
sure that you understand here I agree
with Pelosi here yeah I think she's
weird and creepy but I agree with her
when people suggested that Bernie
radicalized ask Alicia how dare they say
such a thing how dare are they for them
to all of a sudden be sanctimonious as
if they don't never seen such a thing
before you you know what though with you
Nancy Pelosi everyone has the right to
be sanctimonious like that's the thing
it's like how dare you get sanctimonious
usually I'm not a sanctimonious guy but
you're Nancy Pelosi so you brought down
I'll take that liberty right now you
were denied Communion and your face is
removable I don't know I like
sanctimonious is only the position to be
taken when discussing something with
Nancy Pelosi
here's one thing to I Trump is
absolutely hard in the media okay in
conclusion no name that movie line would
comment below
ah does he ever accuse him of murders oh
no the media or of being terrorists or
should I say I shouldn't even say ever
does he consistently accuse them of
murder or family members of murder or
being terrorists or of radicalizing more
people than Isis again someone calls you
when he said they were evil he was
talking about the media who came forward
and said that Cavanaugh needed to step
down because someone came forward with
know who what where when why accusing a
man of being a gang rapists and all the
people who said we know
this isn't true were accused themselves
of being evil he said look there's no
evidence evil stuff evil stuff folks
that's as bad as the actual possibly
false accusation folks accusations of
rape let's just say that where's
Christine Fork aside from a GoFundMe
that's now what accrued is it is it a
million dollars $800,000 from the club
what does she have to gain by lying I
present to you exhibit a and B in seeing
Dean there's about a million exhibits so
yeah listen there have been acts of
violence committed on both sides I think
we would agree about that
charlottesville terrible sorry
alarm clock he was their alarm clock
what do you think Charlotte Phillips
everyone was mocking Charlotte's ville
before it even happened you had people
who would be considered all right
mocking it and people who aren't even
considered all right myself and a late
good friend
oh and Bentley this is ridiculous and
people with Walgreens tiki torches this
is absurd of course they don't there was
like 20 people
it was terrible though so you have that
example and you have alarm clock
packages that's about it mass violence
as a movement is exclusive to the left
what was it less luminous what was the
last conservative Baltimore oh that's
right wing Portland ant if I'm pulling
people out of cars and punch them in the
face what was a lot of time yet
conservatives knocking people out at
airports amass because of hashtag fight
for 15 right well although I can
somewhat doesn't need me for a fillet of
Fisheries are gonna automate it I'm
gonna go punch an old lady at the carry
on its carousel this is what happens
black lives matter often cops remember
the Dallas shooting that's more than all
right wing extremists combined recently
any anything comparable when was the
last version you know what let's even
scale it back from that
Tea Party's back then and I know a lot
of you were around at this point Tea
Parties protesting taxes from Barack
Obama would actually leave public parks
cleaner than they found it
Occupy Wall Street they were throwing
aids ridden towels on a pond by the way
fellow protesters tense
black lives matter Baltimore anything
comparable on mass as an actual movement
coming from the right okay I'll wait
I'll wait bring it comment about you
evil bastards hey you or if you like
this video you first off should probably
seek counseling but you should
subscribe or hit the notification bell
or watch one of these videos that's
playing what truth is I don't know what
any of that means anymore if you try and
subscribe it's a notification bell you
won't be notified and if you try to
click one of these videos it's just
going to take you to BuzzFeed boldly fat
prods as they get carried out of their
houses we like to break down the north
wall and they get carried out in a land
well tarp I don't know what's happening
on YouTube I know what's happening with
mug Club ladders credit.com slash month
let me get to watch The Daily Show one
hour every single day not just clips
along with like 15 other shows for 69
dollars annually if your student and/or
veteran or military and you get to keep
us here on YouTube for free because we
can we can irritate them by your support
it's worth it right